i believe we are live
okay bye
just go what's up
[Music]
how's it going
what's up justin brock
or tangled
where is this
hello jaden rage origin gaming
504 med love life blazing daniel ahmed
cat attacker joseph let's go all right
it's a little too fast right now
hi sue let's see rocket
is right here
she's right there in the chair
she knows she's on camera apparently
and kyrie's in the other room
i'll have to
move over now
hello everyone hello hello hello
miss
alma said miss marvel she-hulk episode
three
it is late as late as late i will be
getting on off kind of early
um
kind of early after we get off
after the episode ends because i gotta
wake up really really early and that
doesn't really work when you're uh you
know staying up till like 3 4 a.m uh
doing these watch parties so i'm gonna
try to get to bed
as early as possible tonight
so who's excited for episode four i i
believe i enjoyed this one
i'm trying to remember just like my
reactions
of
like when i because i saw the first two
at my house and then i saw no i saw the
the first one at my house and then i saw
the first the the next three
one
two three four
i saw them at the launch event the
premiere i remember thinking the fourth
one was good
form one was good i think i liked it
more than the third
not sure how much i really like the
third one to be honest
so
i think this one is
this one's definitely better than the
third mr anderson the best mod is in the
chat what is going on
what is going on what is going on
got it
uh
i don't remember the post credit scene
but as
as i told you guys i i'll say this
because i don't want you to get your
hopes up daredevil's not in this episode
now i've only seen up to episode four
this is the last episode i've seen
um so i can only say that this week but
i know daredevil's not in this episode
um
uh
yeah i can't really see if there's
cameos
i mean there is because
um
they they've already like showed it in a
trailer
or tv spot one of one of the two um
not daredevil i'm sorry i'm not trying
to get everyone's hopes up i'm not
trying to like bum everybody out you
know
but it's not daredevil sorry
they typically like
volume up
can you guys hear me actually i haven't
even checked
i haven't even checked youtube if the
stream's working well
i'm sorry
they typically like
williams it's fine it might be i talk
low every now and then because i'm tired
as heck right now
um
but marvel typically only sends us you
know
the episodes that don't have like the
major spoilers in them and the reason
they do that is because
it would be great if everybody was like
super trustworthy and
you know you could just trust everybody
to not reveal anything major but
unfortunately like that's not how it is
because you also get like a plus one
most of the time most of the time you
know if you if you're in pretty good
like i always get a plus one
um
and depending on who you invite it could
just be like a friend or somebody and
they might not care at all and they
might go and you know
reveal everything hey daredevil shows up
in episode two and does this and this
this and that's what he says like what
do they care you know like they don't
they don't think they can get in trouble
but they can get the person that brought
them in trouble but typically they don't
share
the episodes that have all that big
stuff you know
so
hey jeff coming up with the super chat
always every week i super appreciate
that man i really do love the show my
wife loves it too can't wait to see what
cameos planned for today i i okay i just
remembered what this episode is and i
like it
um
i
i don't wanna say anything i don't to
say anything i don't want to like spoil
anything where
we're
11 12 minutes away
i'm sorry 13 minutes away i'm tired i'm
so tired if i
if i'm slow to pick up on things today
um that is why and normally i'd be
drinking my g fuel
um but i got to wake up really early in
the morning so i have crystal light and
a big water jug instead because i'm
trying to stay hydrated and lose weight
and diet mountain dew
so no
g fuel tonight as sad as that is
but of course elgato sponsors the stream
as well thank you so much to elgato for
providing me with all my awesome studio
equipment
they really are pretty awesome they're
awesome to work with
it's the dating episode when nikki set
up dinner for a tender date and the dude
wants to get wants to get hulk smashed
in bed
this is that episode yes
yes where did i get the chair
um this is called and a seat i think
that's their name right there
um
i got them as like a trade
they wanted me to
shout them out in videos and stuff like
that and you know just kind of put it in
my videos so people can go wow where'd
you get that chair and i could go and a
seat um so i got it from from anderson
they're really nice um i will say
there are some higher and lower end ones
like this one's really awesome is the
iron man one
the spider-man one
kind of what it's not that it wasn't
comfortable it was a little too big for
me
um but i think you can make like
adjustments and stuff like that so
um bernicus thompson i believe this
episode is better
yes enchantrex how's it going
welcome welcome welcome you have a check
mark by your name
what does that mean
are you are you over a hundred thousand
on youtube is that what that means
that's really interesting i've never
seen that before
um what time is it here sue
uh almost one
almost one almost one hello hello
hello hello hello
everybody
um i feel like i just read
the second half of a comment and i
missed the f
first here uh and rick uh there is
uh spider-man and iron man captain
america
an
ant-man and they and i think they come
out with new models i haven't looked in
to them yet
oh i don't know that enchantrex
is your channel
called enchantrix because that's really
cool that's really awesome
i think i tried to look you up before
and couldn't find you huh but
congratulations that's a huge super huge
accomplishment
did i see
the iphone 14
no what iphone do i have
this is the 13 i don't even know i had
the one below this
and there was like nothing wrong with it
at all
like externally
i had i didn't have a scratch on it like
literally a scratch on it
and it it kind of crapped out on me and
just stopped working and i was like why
and it stopped working at star wars
celebration out of all places luckily i
had a spare phone with me
um because i have like a work phone
uh
and yeah it was i had to use that damien
warner will i be doing a watch party for
doors well hey if we want to sit down
and watch thor love and thunder
we can do that you're just going to sit
there watching me laugh so if you don't
like thor love and thunder don't don't
come to the stream because i really like
the movie a lot
um
there was a
there was how to spell the chair
a n d a
seat
drill mix hello
welcome to the
stream
welcome welcome welcome
thanos is in the new she-hulk episode
i don't recall that
i would not count on that at all
uh weasel games that's you're you're
funny thank you for for uh
for for
posting i thought you were asking me do
i actually like she hulk yeah i do
yeah
i don't think it's groundbreaking by any
means i think there's a lot of cool
stuff to it i'm here for the ride and i
think it's funny
i
i could i was in need of a show like
this i will say a light-hearted show
that cracks jokes that you know does the
fourth wall breaking
i just
i don't take it
that seriously because i don't think
it's meant to be taken that seriously
while at the same time it's got some
serious stuff in it that i can
appreciate
but i get hit with a lot of laughs which
i can also appreciate and that's why i
like thor so much like yeah there could
have been
some parts that was like a lot like you
know a bit more serious and they could
have
just stayed in the serious moments
instead of just gotten out of it with a
joke but i still really loved thor love
and thunder
i really did
i really did
um do you think with how the no way home
villains coming into 616 before they
died do you
think the same happened to toby
and andrew spider-man meaning like did
they come right before they die
died uh no i i don't believe that i i
would really hope they didn't get sent
back to their universe and like died
right away um
no i don't think so
uh
ares
will the boss be revealed by the end of
she-hulk oh i really really hope so like
i said this is the
um
i've only seen up to this episode
so i don't know
i don't know what comes
after this i really don't know jeff
likes k-pop what's up another member in
the chat how's it going
i'm dead tired as well yes
i'm very dead tired as well it's very
late i saw another member in the chat
oh bruce gotcha gotcha
just want to make sure mentioning the
members in the chat
malik king what's going on what's up
sarah little yeet
love it
hey daniel well happy belated birthday
how's it going
uh nmg smash my number one marvel movie
is spiderman noir home it's a great
choice my friend great
choice
uh do i think midnight suns might be in
phase six ah
sadly no
i really don't
sorry i i think that comes in phase
seven
i think
i think they are going to start to
introduce these other aspects of like
the supernatural part of the marvel
cinematic universe and maybe like start
to introduce the mutants a little bit
but i don't think we really get like
it's all about these
until phase seven
i think it's gonna stick with the whole
multiverse thing
theme you know and then i think
i think after that
you know it ends with secret wars and i
think that's gonna end like at least
kind of end the multiverse
saga you can't you can never just get
rid of the multiverse unless they really
are planning on just like at the end of
secret wars go oh there's only one
universe now which i don't think they
should do
i really don't think they should do
so
uh
thank you archer neil almighty corey you
think ghost rider will be a cameo in the
show uh there's an easter egg kind of
pointed towards him that we saw in one
of the trailers
that you'll see in this episode
uh sue what about werewolf by night
we're supposed to get that like in in
october like two months from now um
i haven't heard anything about that
recently and it hasn't even been
officially announced yet
which is kind of
concerning but
from what i've heard we're supposed to
get into october so
you know
well we have four minutes left i should
get
disney plus ready i suppose
oh i am tired tonight
i'm tired tonight my friends uh what is
this
disney plus
does anybody have the
the samsung galaxy flip phone i want to
know
how that is that reminds me of high
school because i had a flip phone in
high school
and i'm real i'm really curious to like
if
i don't know
how it is
and how's like the crack in the screen
right there's got to be like a crack in
the screen
so
do i think doctor doom will be in
wakanda zaleswa number i'm assuming you
mean what kind of forever
i do
um
i don't think he'll really be in the
movie i think he'll probably be a
post-credits scene or they'll
severely hint at him at some point in
time in the movie
it's it's weak no it's weak i don't
i don't know if you're referring to the
phone
we're having
i'm having i'm seeing i'm reading like a
lot of different conversations in the
chat right now
oh nokia phone that takes me back too
samsung galaxy s9 see i don't really
know samson i don't
really know what that is
uh gambit no i i really hope channing
tatum though does show up in secret wars
as gambit he he at least deserves that
cape town south africa justine trevor
dang
be watching thor love and thunder nice
it sounds like a good time you have uh
coming up here the next few hours enjoy
it enjoy it
uh weasel games you know
i think it's tailored to specific
like
genre i don't know if that's the right
word
it's a very specific genre
um and i can totally get how some people
think it's a little too much um
i kind of take things like that
to heart
um
when
it's like hard for me to like relate to
things like i'm not a woman
you know so it doesn't make me mad
um
that's just kind of how i view it i
think it's i think it's important for
things to be stated for other people's
sakes right just because it's not
something for me it doesn't mean it's
not something for other people
like
i always try to like avoid talking about
this but i really don't like captain
marvel i didn't like the movie
i am one of those people who thought
brie larson was way too serious but i do
like what the movie did for like
you know the little girls out there who
dressed up as captain marvel and thought
it was really cool
ah thank you kevin regalido
regalado i'm so sorry if i did not
pronounce that right
john cena is the thing luann vance i
would
love that
i heard that tick tock recently had like
a really big
like leak with the and like actually my
sister-in-law
had a friend who like her bank account
was like something happened with her
bank account and tick tock and i'm just
like this is why i've always been
hesitant towards tick tock
uh guys i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
gotta just tell you that daredevil's not
in this episode i'm sorry
i'm sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
it was an important date i'm stranded
jeez
i don't i don't i don't know
i don't remember what the post credit
for this was
i like i really don't know
oh you know what i need to
[Music]
okay okay okay okay hold on i need to
get a thing
mr anderson i call it something
different every time stopwatch stop
watch
you need to get that up
move tap to new window
[Music]
good all right we are about to start
let me refresh it
and there it is
is this not real magic i did enjoy this
episode a lot so we're gonna start this
in five
four
three
two
one go
oh wait hold on
it's still in korean hold on
there we go
how do i
there we go
pb and jen hi jen
good to see you
why can't i minimize
there we go
man i don't i really don't remember
what the post-credits scene is for this
i i really i really don't know thank you
the street appreciate that
man i don't remember
i think the post credit was i don't
think it sets up anything i would have
walked away from the theater going like
wow
i i think it's silly
i think it's something silly like you
know they typically have like they
typically have been
no guys you know i really wish i could
show the video but look
marvel blocks it
see like this is this is what i'm
watching right now you can even see
like it says she-hulk attorney at law
and the timer's even running i see it on
my screen
but i can't see it
i can't see it on the stream i see it
right here so whatever technology they
have like kudos to them it's amazing i
i used to be able to show it now i can't
so now we just kind of you know do the
timer thing and watch together all right
here it is let's go
you could literally see the rope
oh this girl i actually really like this
girl
two n's and one why
oh my gosh
it's donnie blaze guys it's freaking
isn't that such like a tease
johnny blaze ghost rider donnie blaze
marvel knew what they were doing
look what he's got
he's got a sling ring
please please please please please
you see like the there's like a
a head on like a spear in the background
yeah there's like a head on like a spear
behind him
all right cat tiger i'll see ya mr cat
look where little here's wong
i like this episode i remember
tip
hmm
that's not good
the sopranos
spoilers
you just ruined it
[Laughter]
i love that i love that donnie blaze is
going to pay for this
fourth wall break
i love that that i part twitter armor
for the week i love that
it's wong in time
i love how he's still like
a dad i love how he's still like trying
to take care of his little girl even
though she's a hulk
it's amazing how little this episode i
i remember
back to the cgi
oh yeah that's the interview that she
did last time
hey look it's wrong again
magician
former student
that's so funny he's a chad pretty much
could be a setup but who knows
no
no
we answer to a higher power
i think donnie blaze might be a ralph
boner situation tony f uh skillfrenzy
donnie blazes kind of sounds like a
knockoff of johnny blaze who was
ghostwriter a version of ghostwriter
i love how wonka can just like what you
when the portal opens up here's the clip
that we saw
today
no this guy
this guy sucks
guys don't ever do that and girls if
someone ever does that to you
run away
gosh
but a little judge but a little judgment
it's a numbers game
anybody who's been on a dating app knows
it's a numbers game
no news in the kang dynasty yet sadly
as she-hulk
except you're gonna be she hulk
i don't remember
but
but i am more mystical in my sleep
love love that
this guy's the worst
yep
oh this guy sucks
this guy sucks oh this guy sucks
oh just the worst
oh this is like
this is like just the worst
just the worst
donnie blaze not johnny it's not
ghostwriter
there's an idea
good geez
wait is that the dude from entourage
is that billy from entourage i don't
know if it is
oh the witness it might be yeah it might
be yeah you're right
wongers
i love it i love her her character's so
funny
where is she partying where it's broad
daylight in l.a
[Laughter]
wongers
she's like pissed about the roses
his name's mafisto
uh
i already know
i already know the mephisto stuff is
coming
the mephisto is the demon ones
wondrous assemble
yep i already see it starting with fisto
confirm it's mephisto
jacob's mephisto confirmed
these guys suck
everyone sucks
the lawyer's a magician
jake lockley
i'm sure there's a universe where all
the avengers are wrong
every dimension
few weeks jeez
the lawyer put it there
eventually
mephisto will be revealed
people are clapping really
he probably won't even die i love it
poor wong for wangers he just wants to
watch the sopranos he wants to watch the
sopranos without spoilers
i definitely think
i definitely think marvel is now teasing
us with mephisto stuff and i feel like
they could have broken the fourth wall
and she could have been like do you
think it's mephisto or something like
that like she could have done it
she could have done it
they could have broke the fourth wall
about mephisto missed opportunity
dang it
oh
it's jesse it's a kpop song i love it so
much it's zoom by jesse
i see you looking at my p.i.c
think
zoom in
zoom out
zoom in
zoom out love it i love jesse she's
awesome
of course she's getting all these guys
trying to smash
she
this guy
because of my cousin incredible
i feel like this would be like
one of us if we ever met like a
superhero like a new superhero
what a specimen
i can attest dating in year 36
and then all of a sudden
she's a little interested
she
she she was very quick to
to to go home
[Laughter]
in the comics she sleeps with so many
people though
like really she does it's it's it's kind
of funny she gets kicked out of the
avengers uh headquarters
duh
oh yeah i think i remember this part
maybe
oh no i remember yeah it gets a little
interesting
yep and then it's just little yep
i remember
no that's that's never never a good no
that thing grew fast
uh i don't think this series is gonna be
the the turning point i really i really
don't
we'll close the hole now you dummy
and then all the little things come out
he just wants to watch the sopranos
doing this for the universe not you
call my lawyer
i want to say something but i'm not
going to until the scenes are over but i
really do want to say it
you're saying all the right stuff aren't
you
it's almost too perfect
of course you just take your shirt off
right away
she takes his shirt
and salt
be a hulk
yeah there you go
mephisto is probably there
demons
that's cool i like that a lot how he
like he moved the port a little bit
donnie blaze oh wow look at that
but it does always oh that guy got
bigger
he passed
uh
oh this is cool
a little little
tornado action
it's convenient she landed on him like
that but she's got some stuff on her
that's just demon claw
just like in the comics
she gets around
i don't know about squeezing your own
orange juice
that's nice
oh that's the i think that i think our
yeah
douchebag
i wanted to say something everyone's
like this guy's cool
and i'm just sitting there like he sucks
um
misuse of a trademark
she-hulk
i don't remember the tag
oh yes i do i i thought i remembered it
wonders
they're like best friends now
wanners and madison with
two n's and one y but not everything
i don't know whose wedding it was
gin and tonic
[Laughter]
bottomless gin and tonic
i think that's the only tag i remember
seeing
yeah that's the only one
and there there you have it
yeah i uh i could i could probably watch
a show with madison and wongers i and
and be perfectly happy in all honesty
i don't know why i just find that so
funny i like seeing like because wong's
always like super super serious
and it's you're not even like
you're not even seeing like a lighter
side of him because he's like pretty
serious
um and serious stuff is happening but
just the funny things happened to him is
is really really funny
this episode is 10 mongers longer is
great yeah i
i i like her and wong's relationship
i think the longest thing is uh it's
really great let's get rid of this
i did it
so there you have it
there it is
at least someone found a cute girl
uh
yeah wong is
he's he's in uh
like everything now right i mean he's
gonna be
i think he's going to be you know at the
center he's going to be a really
prominent character
like really so
we shall see uh
well
i would like to know what everybody
thought of that episode
let's do
let's rank from a plus to f minus
how about that
can we do that
do you think johnny blazes donnie
blaze's brother now this is gonna be
just like a huge a huge thing right
and my answer is i believe so because
you also have to think of like
well how did donnie blaze get to the
carmitage how did donnie blaze
you know
be able to become an apprentice sorcerer
so there's something there right it's
not like donnie was just nobody and
johnny you know
they could say that his name is
brother's name is donnie in this you
know
um
let me take a look here
yeah
i mean
not seeing anything for donnie blaze
marvel
i know there's danny ketch but
i don't think
i really don't think
donny is you know
like i don't think he's about that i i
would say you know he's probably
johnny blaze's brother why not right
yeah and then of course there was
mephisto
oh wait there's a bunch of ratings okay
hold on hold on
[Music]
okay okay okay
do i think jake could be nick fury's
brother
jillian
jake the one that she said was a demon
is that who you're talking about
hmm
because i'm confused
interesting i just get pretty good
reviews from you guys
you guys yeah
yeah interesting interesting interesting
madison she was
she was good i still think the first
episode is probably the best
i know right jeff i wanted this i like
wanted to say it so bad i was like
there's a k-pop reference in in episode
four
i was just listening to that song today
it's such a good song that's a good song
good so jake from state farm well he's a
guy so
me and my friends say that all the time
wanger is with the spoilers for sopranos
i feel so bad for him
silly wongers
yeah
i i i'm looking here and i just don't
see
i don't see anything i've never i've
never heard of a donnie blaze i know
there's danny catch
nope
i'm not i'm not seeing anything
i think it's just a made-up person i
think it's just like really just like
this teaser
um
i really think it's just like this
teaser for ghost writer like
in all
honesty
i mean
yeah
that's what i think
now uh
johnny has i think danny ketch is
johnny's brother
and it's like danny donny like the
little play on it i'm just kind of
sitting there like
would they would they really
do that would they really change like
danny to donny
and have him be you know
brother like
i think they would
in all honesty like i think they would
in order to keep things fresh right
because they just can't copy
you know what they do in the comics
because we all just we know everything
right so
so yeah
it's definitely a hint a nod an easter
egg whatever you want to call it towards
ghostwriter like for sure
it definitely is
yeah um
the cgi of this episode luminary
i mean in the beginning when she was i
feel like it's like when she's in her
office it's not the best but when she's
like outside of her office it's okay
so
uh the jake demon thing hinting towards
something um
skull frenzy i
you know what i'm gonna say i'm gonna
say like mephisto
but who knows i
again i think this was like a really
great opportunity for
jim walters to break the fourth wall and
go mephisto but she you know they didn't
feel like they didn't jump on that i
feel like they should have jumped on
that
i feel like they really should have
jumped on that
yeah the goat demon thing that they were
fighting yeah i just i really you know
i hate to throw the name back out there
but i also don't hate to throw the name
back out there mephisto
that was clearly some type of a hell
world and they clearly showed us that in
doctor strange it's interesting that it
popped up twice
so
uh donnie blaze could be johnny blaze
towards human torture
yeah barucus uh i think i think he might
be
a relative or a brother of johnny
wish they make the scene in court
serious
uh oh like with the magic and everything
in
various easter eggs in one division
episode one or two but you didn't really
see any of them
hmm
yeah i will say
um i don't see cause so this is as far
as i've seen so far right i haven't seen
uh episodes five through nine
i haven't seen the overall
arc of the show
right i don't know what
because each episode kind of seems like
one off
they
briefly mentioned um
abomination a meal in this episode sorry
i'm tired
i don't know if they're coming back to
that i don't know if that's going to be
some type of a setup
thunderbolt something like that i don't
know if titania is going to be like the
main villain i'm pretty sure she is but
it's like
the episodes are entertaining but
nothing's really happened
unless they really are going to dive
further into like wong
in which case it's like
what an interesting direction to take
she-hulk like with with wong with like
the mystic arts and stuff like that so
i'm like really sitting there wondering
like
what direction is the show gonna go
and it could be good it could be bad so
let's hope it's good
let's hope it's good
um
yeah thor 11 thunder it's uh technically
out on disney plus right now depending
on where you live
um i know some countries get in some
don't and the various time zones and
so yeah that's definitely not johnny
blaze for those asking i definitely
don't think that is ghost writer i think
it's maybe a relative to him maybe a
brother or something like that um
uh yeah keith i i don't know what the
overall story is that's kind of um
my complaint right now is that like it
doesn't seem to be going anywhere
and
i mean it's not
seinfeld right it's seinfeld it's like
every episode is just some random thing
it's like it is part of the mcu
and i feel like i need an overall story
right and i don't feel like there is any
story at all right now
that is at least connected
see you jd ultra
see you see us here see erica b
have fun
yeah the boss for the wrecking crew is
the only thing but it's like
are they working for titania is titania
working for somebody else like
i don't know i have to wait and see but
i'm sorry to end this so early today i
have to go to bed i have a very very
early um doctor's appointment in the
morning so
i really gotta get to bed and i'm
already really tired as it is but um
seems like a lot of people like this
episode so i'm glad
uh yeah that guy was a douchebag who she
hooked up with
um and like really like he didn't even
hide
being a douchebag he was just like i'm
gonna go
don't worry about my sweater just kind
of like come on man like
could have been nicer about it
douchebag
but uh thank you so much to everybody
for stopping by the live stream today
we'll be back at it next week and i
i haven't seen episode five
so i'll be watching it for the first
time with you all next week so
i'm excited for that
um
to ahmed thank you so much uh school
friends yeah do you think the leader
could be the villain
um i hope wang and maddie smash i i i
hope so too
uh damian warner thanks so much for that
super chat great watching with you as
well woof and uh yeah thank you thanks
for joining thank you to everybody for
joining
um thanks for the super chats the
regular chats everybody's just watching
love you all you're awesome and uh get
some sleep depending on where you're at
and if it's already daytime have a great
day have a great night wherever you are
thank you to mr anderson you can check
out his youtube channel he posted the
link there um
he's got content on there
and
of course mr anderson shout out to you
from an awesome mod um
yeah what time is it usa it's uh about
two o'clock for me so it's uh
it's pretty late it's pretty late pretty
late yeah we need everybody ships longer
than madison so
i definitely do all right
love you all i will catch you next time
love you and every universe